you wouldn't change anything if you had
all of your bills taken care of the rest
of your life you'd never have to work
again
and then you can cheat and yeah yeah so
you just have to oh hello yeah
yeah so like no so he would have rules
with the cheating okay so this is the
rules would be no stds no outside kids
no one would ever find out about it no
you would never find out about it like
you he would never put it in your face
so you you essentially yeah yeah yeah so
this is upfront you know so i love love
so for me it's the emotional part like i
cannot imagine my man being with someone
else at all i don't care
you know they say love is a young
person's game
because when you get older she gets more
the reason women have to get married is
because they need to get 2.5 million to
retire like people need 2.5 million in
the bank account to retire it's very
hard to do that off of one income
so i feel like the
that's the idea of marriage and
relationships love is not
love is not like a social construct like
love is
it's like
deeper than people think so you can fall
in love but
with someone else but because this guy's
more stable whatever you're gonna go
with the more stable guy but
love is like uncontrollable like you
can't really like contain it
i've just never thought love was enough
like love love isn't enough for a
marriage yeah
yeah
yes good point
we have a whole generation of people
that are raised like these these
rom-coms and disney fairy tales that
think oh yeah
i'm
and it's going to be great we might have
one problem and then we're going to run
together in the street and hug and kiss
like
it doesn't work like that what you're
saying is so important
and people need to understand like so
much so much things come to come come
into it like heritage and like um
occupation and
like upbringing as well culture so many
things come into it like marriage is a
contract at the end of the day i mean
it's not like
yeah and and raise the little versions
of us to
[Music]
well said very well said yeah no i
actually i agree with you i think that's
the reason a lot of relationships failed
today is it's all based on yes like how
we feel and like the exciting guy you
know like that's and it comes to an end
very soon yeah because i mean
if you want to have like kids and a
family you only have so long to like
pick one exactly
so but it's interesting what do you
think people base their partners on like
in like what makes you say that
because i think okay so this comes
this is
this stems from a conversation i had a
friend about
interracial dating okay and i'm all for
loving who you want dating who you want
but my thought process came from the
fact that is people don't understand the
the things that come with it
so
a lot of a lot of them end
abruptly
from what i've seen close close around
to me because a lot of people get into
it based on initial attraction and like
we get along but then
over a couple of years like okay well
the nuances come into it from different
different things within their culture
and then it's like okay so
this small thing well let me class
in this small thing and those small
things start to add up so
i was going to say so
so what you're basically saying is you
can fall in love with anyone but you
can't be in a relationship with anyone
100
yeah you fell in love like i think you
need to be friends you know and like
start to imagine what kind of life you
would have with that person like you
know i think status and who they are
even though you have feelings for that
person you need to know go be realistic
yeah exactly
because would you see yourself if
someone has no job has no
i mean has no career has no ambition and
then you want to you know it changes the
whole picture change the whole picture
so i think we should be very careful
before we fall in love i think we should
be always first like friends
and then see if you have a future with
that person there's one issue with the
whole friend thing though
and i'm actually i've always thought
that it's like oh yeah let's be friends
first but at the same time it's like all
right
[Music]
[Music]
it's
yeah i don't um so just make sure you're
going really close okay okay
um
okay tell me if that's better in the
chat guys i know you guys are saying
everyone in black is echoing so i think
so make sure you're just going like
really close to the mic when we talk
um
okay so
tell me
um okay so we were talking about
relationships and why they fail
do you think social media is one of the
reasons relationships fail
yes
you'd say it's the biggest reason
probably why
just the whole grass is greener thing
everyone's always seeing different guys
like i remember like even going from my
tick tock tick tock is demon i'll go
through my for you page
maybe it's my specific algorithm i don't
know but it's just girl oh
it's based on what you want
yeah but
it got put in front of me in the first
place for me to have looked at it do you
know what i mean i don't type in hot
girls no but you like the ones yeah but
uh yeah the phone does listen to you
phones but that's another conversation
oh yeah listen it got initially put in
front of me i liked it and now it just
keeps coming up tick tock is good for
that because it knows it's like it knows
what so what you spend more time
watching or what you're liking or what
you're
it's recommending more videos like for
that so like whatever's coming up on
your feed is what you enjoy the most
obviously it's not just that but like
that's there as well that's what i'm
trying to say
but it's just the temptation element
that like you know what i mean the grass
is green i think as i said at the
beginning i think it's more for girls
because i feel like guys once they
finally go on and everything they just
kind of settle
and they're good
you know what i mean though like the
guys don't leave the guys don't leave
they don't
[Music]
have you guys ever cheated
i have no comment oh
why that's honest oh that's very honest
i'm not happy with
the
myself
of the person when they found out
killed me mm-hmm right so yeah yeah
absolutely how did she find out
oh she went with sherlock on the
internet
why are you mumbling
that sounds weird but i was i was like
i just messed up and then she found out
um but yeah yeah i think it was the
reaction
um seeing that reaction to someone else
is just like
i should probably shouldn't do that
again
it hurt you seeing them probably you're
still
because you do not know the person
you're going to be in in five years let
alone five minutes so like
self-control
and about no i understand where he's
coming from though you can never say
yeah
so but yeah um
yeah cheating is a it's a wild one
you shouldn't do it what girls have you
cheated i haven't been in a relationship
you've never cheated no never it's
interesting like guys will admit it
girls won't
i've never i've never i've asked
i've asked a lot of girls on this
platform if they've ever cheated and
i've asked a lot of guys how many of
them said yes never girl really they
would never say no never like you said
like girls and guys define cheating
those different things like
someone could say oh liking a picture is
cheating whereas
but also it's like i feel like it's also
self-preservation because if they come
out and say oh yeah i've cheated a guy
might look at them differently and well
a bunch of guys might look at them
differently not pursue them
whereas as a guy
i can be honest because like i'm i'm
like i'm all about self-improvement and
all that
but like at the end of the day i'm the
one pursuing it so you can you can say
no i believe in my source a goal is not
pursuing
that time
i don't think it really affects like how
do i put it like girl guys the same if
they admit to cheating then a girl is
like well at least he's honest
so i was like well at least he admitted
to it
we're a guy like that she's for the
streets
she's like we could rationalize stuff
like i swear to god sometimes guys be
telling us that they're red flags
they'll tell you and we'll just be like
well he told us
oh he was honest girls think they can
change you black ah i don't want to know
how much i don't want any of that stuff
i'm gonna do this like the black oh it's
fine that's fine
yeah they'll try and change trying to be
fixed
we're trying to fix things
okay